*Soothing music plays as the chef puts down a cutting board made of the finest wood available, Bamboo— or is it Oak– no wait, maybe Maple?*
*The chef cleans the cutting board made of the finest wood available*
splish sploosh
*shake shake shake*
*The chef grabs a knife as it makes a satisfying 'shing'*
*The chef begins to cut the finest peppers known to man on the cutting board made of the finest wood available* *Bell Pepper cutting sound*
*Bell pepper cutting ASMR*
*The chef turns on the stove*
*The chef places a marvellous pan on the stove*
*The chef melts some butter in preparation of frying the finest peppers*
*The chef puts water in a pot to boil the spaghetti (without sauce, of course)*
*The chef prepares to boil the pot that will cook the spaghetti (Again, without sauce)*
*The chef grabs the finest peppers available from the cutting board made from the finest wood available- sans gloves, because gloves are for plebs- and deposits them into the pan*
*silent admiration to the sexy sound of sizzling veggies*
*The chef sautés the finest peppers available that were chopped on the cutting board made of the finest wood available, in the pan*
*fwoomp*
*The chef continues to sauté the finest peppers available that were chopped on the cutting board made of the finest wood available, in the pan*
*another fwoomp*
*The chef cooks broccoli along with the peppers but did not show the preparation of the broccoli for the sake of suspense*
*sexy sizzle noises continue*
*The chef opens the lid of the pot that will be used to cook the spaghetti (again, sans sauce)*
*The chef puts the finest spaghetti available in the pot*
*The chef tries to open a bottle of the finest champagne available*
*Flawless execution*
*the chef places a wine glass down because champagne flutes are too small*
*The chef fills the glass with the finest champagne available*
*oops*
*the chef removes the spaghetti from the heat and strains it*
*shake shake shake*
*the chef places the spaghetti on a plate made with the finest material available*
*the chef arranges the broccoli and the finest peppers available that were chopped on the cutting board made of the finest wood available beside the spaghetti*
*The chef awkwardly removes the fallen piece of broccoli, the candle and the champagne glass, as she suddenly decided to drink a tankard of water*
*The chef licks her lips, ready to taste the wonderful  meal*
*the chef enjoys her meal, and the accompanying background music*
*the chef enjoys a piece of broccoli*
*the chef congratulates herself on a meal well cooked*
*jazz hands*
*the chef thinks about having more spaghetti, but then stops herself after realising how good the broccoli is*
*the chef has more broccoli*
*pieces of broccoli fall out of the chefs mouth, but the chef does not mind*
*the chef licks the broccoli*
*the chef plays with the spaghetti as she tries to get some more broccoli*
*the chef spots the spaghetti and eats it*
*the chef tries some peppers*
*the chef brushes herself*
*the chef eats more spaghetti*
*the chef picks up the plate to grab any food under it*
*the chef licks a pepper*
*the chef licks the entire plate*
*the chef eats some more spaghetti*
*the chef conducts some sort of spell*
*the chef scratches her ear*
*the chef gives a thumbs-up. the chef approves of the meal!*
*the chef smiles as she gives another thumbs up! she really enjoyed the meal! hooray!*
*the chef approves very much.*
*the chef has a few more bites*
the chef is satisfied with his work